when you hear of ancient rome or the
roman empire the roman republic
immediately images of the roman legions
come to mind these conquering armies
conquering much of the mediterranean you
might have images of the roman senate
names like julius caesar and augustus
might come to mind you might think of
some of the famous arctic architecture
some of which you can still see if you
were to visit rome and these are all
real images of rome or they're
appropriately associated with it and
we'll talk about most of these things in
some depth but rome did not start out
that way and the purpose of this video
is to give us an overarching arc of the
history of rome to be able to place it
within history both in terms of time and
geography
so just to make sure we can read what i
did here ahead of time is i have up here
as i have a high level timeline and then
down here i have a timeline that zooms
in a little bit goes into a few more
details and you can see this timeline on
top
it's going from the 8th century bce all
the way to the 5th century ce so it's
covering over 1 000 years of history and
i needed to cover over 1000 years of
history because the roman empire right
we could even say just the the western
roman empire covers that much and that
doesn't even cover the entire legacy of
the roman empire because when we get
into the 4th century
the 4th century ce you have a split
where you have the eastern and the
western roman empire and the eastern
often known as the byzantine empire that
goes on until 1453
ce so another thousand years until they
are conquered by the ottomans so the
legacy of the roman empire even formerly
as an empire is significant
and then it continues on much of western
civilization especially europe and the
mediterranean has its foundations in the
roman empire and then before that greek
civilization and the roman empire is
really up there alongside the persian
empire is one of the really great
civilizations or empires and when i say
great you should take that with a grain
of salt great i'm saying it was big it
was powerful but not everything they did
was great they had a lot of slavery they
were very cruel they were sometimes very
violent so take these terms great with a
grain of salt
so now that we get this timeline up here
and then down here i'm going to go
whoops
down here i have a
some maps that are going to show how the
roman empire grew and then eventually
splits and declines
but as we go to this top timeline
we see the founding of rome in the 8th
century bce and this date 753 is the
date that's often given to the founding
of rome by romulus one of twin brothers
romulus and remus raised by
a she-wolf they were abandoned and
raised by the she-wolf as legend would
have it and then romulus eventually
kills his brother and then becomes the
first king of rome we don't know how
much of this is true i suspect a lot of
this is very
legendary a legend would have it that
rome is named for romulus
but some historians today think well it
might have been the other way around we
have the city of rome they needed a
founding story hey let's say this person
romulus started it and we don't know the
exact date but there's some there seems
to be a reasonable consensus that around
this you know mid 8th century bce you
have the founding of the city of rome
but it's important to realize that at
that point this the founding of the city
the kingdom of rome it wasn't a
significant power on the italian
peninsula at the time where i have this
x marked that's where rome is and what
you see in green this is actually the
etruscan civilization and for most most
of this
of this period of the roman kingdom so
this period right over here it's
actually the etruscans that are dominant
power and for significant fractions of
this
they were dominant over the roman
kingdom over the city of rome
but as we get to 509 bce this is when
the roman republic is established and in
this blue green color this is the
kingdom the gold color this yellow color
is the republic and then the red color
is the when the empire gets established
by julius caesar and his adopted son
augustus and as we get into this i guess
you could say this republic period of or
into the roman republic this is when it
starts to really exert itself as more of
a dominant influence in the region and
it continues to be a dominant
influence in the region for several
hundred years and then as we get into
the first several hundred years uh in
the common era so after the time of
jesus as we get into the 200s the 300s
this is when we start to see a real
decline of the roman emperor
empire and the western empire at least
gets sacked multiple times in the 5th
century and the year 476 is what's
typically given for the end of the roman
empire but even that's not exactly the
end of the roman empire because in the
4th century you have the roman empire
splitting into this eastern and western
empires and the eastern
later gets known as the byzantine empire
that goes on for another
14 that goes on for another thousand
years until it's as i mentioned i think
earlier taken over by the ottomans but
to get more of appreciation for how the
roman empire
grew and then eventually starts to
shrink i have some maps over here
so this first map this is roughly from
the
the 3rd century bce and 3rd century bce
you might remember rome is a republic at
this time but it's not the dominant
power in the mediterranean just to give
ourselves some bearings you might
remember that
in the
late 4th century bce that's when
alexander
conquers much of
or most of greece macedonia the persian
empire
which include included at the time egypt
and as we get into the third century bce
you still have the the fragments of
alexander's empire that these are still
significant powers in the regions you
also have the carthaginian empire which
you see here in blue in north africa and
southern spain and this period you have
a series of wars between the romans and
the carthaginians known as the punic
wars and we'll do videos in depth on the
punic wars they're called the punic wars
because the term punic it comes from
what the romans called the phoenicians
and carthage was actually set was
actually settled founded by ancient
phoenicians so you could call it you
could kind of consider it's the
phoenician war and or the descendants of
the phoenician wars but the the that's
why it's called punic but the romans
eventually win the the multiple rounds
of punic wars take over their territory
and eventually destroy carthage carthage
is destroyed in 146 bce and we'll talk
more and talk about that in more detail
now as we go into the first century bce
this is when rome goes from being a
republic to an empire and it happens
when the general julius caesar he's able
to conquer gaul for the rome for the
roman republic so gaul is
modern-day france and some other
surrounding regions and he is so
powerful that when he comes back to
to rome
a civil war ensues and julius caesar is
able to essentially win the civil war
declare himself a dictator
and then his adopted son augustus right
over here is in 27 bce declared emperor
and that's the beginning of the roman
empire and we keep going and i think
i've already mentioned it once in this
video but eventually we get a split in
the 4th century
ce where we have eastern and western
halves of the roman empire the western
side centered at rome the eastern side
centered at what was originally
byzantium renamed constantinople and
today istanbul and as we get into the
fifth century that's when the western
empire especially starts to really go
into decline and is eventually sacked in
but the eastern empire keeps on going